the tolerant ones joining us now ben
shapiro himself but we thought of
immediately when we launched this series
Ben you know you don't look too
threatening yeah you're kind of a guy
with some interesting ideas and
thought-provoking conversations and you
freaked them all out got the head gear
on it cut the riot police out it is
funny because it's so pathetic but it's
also very dangerous because you do have
the guts to go on college campuses but
there are a lot of conservatives I know
who are invited to speak you know what
they say and I have better things to do
with my time and in a way you can't
blame them but that is its self chilling
free speech no no question the hecklers
veto that so many universities are now
using to shut down free speech on
college campuses by saying the left is
gonna get violence it's pretty
astonishing and listen I don't blame
conservatives who don't want to take
their life in their hands by going on
some of these campuses now I don't want
to pretend this is happening at every
campus but it is happening to a lot of
conservatives I mean I'm talking about
not even just conservatives I'm talking
about people who range from Jordan
Peterson to Jason Riley to Heather
McDonald to charles Murray now there's
there's a wide variety of conservatives
who are being really rioted against in
some cases on campus and the
administration has in some cases really
not done enough to to prevent that from
happening and when they do attempt to
stop the rise from happening the way
they typically do it is by bringing a
lot of cops on the campus and then by
suggesting that we have to restrict the
number of people who can actually attend
the lectures so they actually end up
restricting free speech even when
they're attempting to protect it in some
cases yeah so again irony the Free
Speech Movement and all started at
Berkeley and Berkeley as is that Center
you know ground cent got a ground zero
of the anti free speech movement in the
United States today in the last couple
of days an interesting development been
that fits with our series at Penn State
the Penn State student power Network
along with other students and community
members gathered outside old main on
Monday to present a list of demands to
President Barron I love it when they
have a list of demands these demands
included denouncing and defunding hate
groups on campus I think to myself oh my
god are the Nazis I mean who's on campus
is the US Communist Party know its
groups with aunt
immigrant rhetoric I don't mean I guess
that's someone who's in favor of
enforcing the border wait what does that
mean I mean everything has been deemed
hate speech on campus up to and
including there's a point during the
election cycle when people were barred
on certain campuses from writing
president Trump's name when he was a
candidate because this made people feel
bad that some people actually supported
Trump as a candidate so the I can only
imagine that anti-immigrant rhetoric
would be things like let's it enforce
our border or let's deport some illegal
immigrants but that that's not a shock
again Penn State is one of the campuses
that I visited and there was a near riot
when I was at Penn State so it's I'm
sure that some of the people who are
protesting against the the conservatives
on campus and it was some conservative
groups who they were protesting now were
some of the same people who a couple of
years ago annually tried to break
through the doors where I was speaking
to disrupt the lecture that I was giving
what's amazing about all of us is that
it is perfectly easy to have a nice
event where people come and listen to me
or listen to any of the other people I
mentioned and all of us are willing to
have q and A's all of us are willing to
have discussions we had one last night
over at Pepperdine where a lot of the
student groups who are on the Left I'm
talking about the same sort of minority
student groups you're hearing about a
Penn State decided that instead of
boycotting they would show up and ask
questions and we had a perfectly nice
conversation but unfortunately there is
a part of the left as distinguished from
I think liberals at large there's
there's a big part of the left and it's
growing that says that it is incumbent
to protect the campus from ideas that
are dissenting and everyone who descends
must be thrown off well and the reason
that they want a stifle speech is
because your speech actually grows
conservatism it spreads the ideology and
it draws people in they have no ideas
they're out of ideas they're out of
solutions they're into demonization and
you know you go to college campuses you
could be going to corporations and
speaking but you go to college campuses
and I think the groups that are trying
to make your life miserable or going
after charlie Kirk and Turning Point USA
go go through the list of who's behind
this effort to really tamp down on free
speech we know some of the big funded
groups by George Soros but go through
that briefly for us I mean that there's
certainly a lot of student groups that
coordinated say that a lot of the groups
that are associated with the women's
March are very much
with this movement a lot of the groups
that were originally associated with
black lives matter were very active in
this campus movement obviously an Tifa
was the the far edge wing of this
movement that was actually promoting
violence and a lot of these speeches but
the the generalized attempt to shut down
speeches by pressuring administrations
that's a lot of student groups that have
been on campus since the time that I was
on college campuses as a student myself
and they continue to push for the idea
that these campuses should be
conservative free and should be complete
safe spaces for people on the left not
only because they think that
conservatives are going to convince a
lot of people but also because they
actually just think conservatives are
evil I think that it's they really think
that people like me are there to do them
harm and when I show up and it turns out
that I'm a relatively non-threatening
character and I've never really beaten
anyone up in my life for several reasons
that you can imagine then you know that
that's the impact